[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter and the
philosopher's stone
more specifically we're going to be
discussing an aspect of the famous book
that you've probably never heard of we
all grew up with the philosopher's stone
and for my generation it was a childhood
staple private drive
platform nine and three-quarters diagon
alley hogwarts
magic these were all pivotal elements
that painted a picture
of a wizarding world that we all fell in
love with the philosopher's stone was
the first harry potter book
which meant that before being published
there wasn't really any proof of concept
jk rowling had the imagination but she
didn't just have the trust of a
respected publisher
and so the wizarding world was
restricted to her mind
and her mind alone eventually the book
was published and the rest of the world
was able to begin
to appreciate her masterpiece but what
many of you probably didn't know
is that the philosopher's stone
underwent many changes before the final
product
the one that hit the shelves was
released in fact the plot for the
philosopher's stone was almost
very drastically different and a page
from a very early version of the book
written in 1991 was and years ago
uploaded to jk rowling's old website
this
singular page contradicted many elements
of the book that we grew up with
and today i want to introduce you to
this very different draft
of the philosopher's stone so this
flamel bloke found the stone
said ron no he made it said harry
he was an alchemist which means someone
who turned space metals into gold said
hermione
she had that old proving i know more
than everyone else look on her face
the other two noticed of course i read
about this in
alchemy ancient art and science by argo
piritis
i missed that one myself muttered ron
and of course it's some of the most
difficult magic you can do
and you end up not just with pure gold
but also with a funny stone thing
which is what i'm on about said harry
the philosopher's stone
yes and it works too it kept nicholas
flamel and his wife
alive for about 500 years what i know
said harry
but it's true he was spotted at the
opera in paris in 1762
he was born back in 13 something ron
whistled
but he's dead now he asked of course
said harry
someone stole his stone so he couldn't
make any more elixir of life
could he it takes a while to make
another stone and by that time
i suppose he was just too old to live
without his elixir
until a new stone was ready and now i'll
tell you something else
really weird that i haven't told you up
to now the stone was found in my parents
safe
gringotts bank but instead of the
interested noises
harry had expected ron and hermione
simply stared at him
what said harry ron cleared his throat
opened his mouth to speak
but shut it again what said harry well
harry said hermione
i mean you mean what he stared at them
both that they shuffled their feet
and tried not to look him in the eye you
don't think he said suddenly and angrily
that my parents stole the stone um said
ron
look said harry furiously that's like
saying they murdered flamel
oh harry we never thought not much you
didn't
said harry i don't know how it got in
there but the stone wasn't put there by
them
right said ron quickly i'm sure you're
right there must be an obvious
explanation said hermione
harry wasn't at all convinced that they
meant it but at that moment
the bell rang which put an end to the
conversation what you just witnessed was
a piece of unpublished history
and a transcript from a page that could
have altered the course of the rest of
the story
in case you didn't pick up on all the
changes the big ones are as follows
first nicholas for mel is already dead
next
the stone was kept in the potter vault
not vault 713
next the stone was actually stolen from
flamel
and lastly by implication the stone
appears to have been stolen by lily and
james potter
so how could this have changed the
course of history
well the possession of a magical
artifact that can result in immortality
is certainly nothing to scoff at and i
can't help but think that
in this reality voldemort's main
preoccupation
would have been to obtain the stone from
the potters not just kill harry
i mean who's to say that the prophecy
would have even existed
what do you guys think had you heard of
this draft before let me know in the
comment section
below until next time it does not do to
dwell on dreams
and forget to live
[Music]
you